merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
mesdames et messieurs les députés
il y a quelques mois devant vous lors de
ma déclaration de politique générale
j'ai appelé tous les groupes de l'arc
républicains à bâtir ensemble au service
de notre pays et de nos concitoyens
dès cet été nous sommes parvenus à nous
mettre d'accord sur des textes pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
il y a quelques jours vous avez voté le
projet de loi relatif au marché du
travail
hier le projet de loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur a été adopté à une très
large majorité au Sénat
en abordant le débat budgétaire nous
connaissions les difficultés face à nous
un budget traduit une ambition et des
engagements
ceux sur lesquels le président de la
République est la majorité se sont
présentés devant les Français
nous aurions pu alors renoncer à la
recherche d'un compromis mais nous avons
fait le choix du dialogue
on passe sur tout
car si nous ne convergeons pas sur tout
nous pouvons nous rejoindre quand
l'intérêt général est en cause
dès cet été le ministre de l'économie et
des finances et celui des comptes
publics ont lancé les dialogues de Bercy
j'ai personnellement reçu tous les
présidents des groupes parlementaires
et ces derniers jours encore en
commission et en séance publique le
débat s'est tenu et nous avons examiné
loyalement toutes les propositions
toutes les idées
mais aujourd'hui de constats s'impose
d'abord au moment où nous parlons au
sixième jour de débat bon nombre
d'amendements sont encore à examiner
[Applaudissements]
et tout indique que nous ne tiendrons
pas les délais prévus pour la discussion
de cette première partie du PLF
[Applaudissements]
ensuite et surtout les oppositions pour
toute réaffirmer leur volonté de rejeter
le texte
en responsabilité nous devons donner un
budget à notre pays
les Français attendent de nous de la
cohérence de l'action et des résultats
[Applaudissements]
aussi
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
le
texte le s'il vous plaît je présente
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît seul madame la Première
ministre à la parole le texte que je
présente aujourd'hui n'est pas le
décalque du projet qui vous a été
initialement soumis il a été nourri
complété amender corrigé même suite au
débat de ces derniers jours en
commission et dans l'émission
une centaine d'amendements a été retenue
y compris des amendements des
oppositions
cette décision c'est le choix de la
responsabilité
car je le redis nous devons donner un
budget à la France un budget cohérent
avec les engagements pris devant les
Français pas de hausse d'impôts pas de
hausse de déficit
mesdames et messieurs les députés
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés ça
n'est pas la fin du débat sur le projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 ce débat
continuera au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée
nationale et à chaque étape nous
garderons intact notre volonté de
dialogue notre devoir d'action et notre
esprit de responsabilité je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]